which character looks the best with
their top off link or girl it's easily
Geralt link looks like a boy so if he's
defending a boy you're wrong and this is
versus the GameSpot show that pits your
favorite games consoles franchises and
hot-button issues against each other
this week we're pitting two of the gray
is to open-world Adventures of the last
couple of years against one another it's
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt vs. The Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild fighting for
The Witcher 3 is Dave Jewett who plans
to model himself after the White Wolf
when he grows old and gray and arguing
the case for Zelda breath of the world
is willpower
who is such a massive zelda fan that he
failed his mastery as he's because he
was busy playing the Wind Waker instead
of revising and look where he is now mr.
Hughes each are going to argue their
corner for their game over the course of
three randomly picked topics the overall
winner being decided by you the
wonderful viewers la Suisse fight
between God of War and the Last of Us
finally saw Oscar knocked down a peg as
his case for Naughty Dog's masterpiece
lost out to me 75% of the votes for God
of War we're going to be throwing up a
clickable poll right here on YouTube
vote for who you think argued their case
best by clicking on the I in the top
right corner at any point during the
video and casting your vote if you're
watching this on GameSpot calm let us
know who you think has won the debate in
the comment section below
right let's get into it
[Music]
Apple hello Dave I see you've bought a
box of your death screams I play this
it's the sound you're gonna make when I
smash your head in
mr. bait you know cut you right off and
wear out my belt or I'm gonna trap you
inside this and bury it under high rule
well we're gonna start this with open
world which game is the best open world
personally I think the world of the
northern realms of The Witcher 3 is the
best the absolute size of the lad is
absolute unit of a game world you've got
the the towns of all that or the cities
of novigrad you go to scaliger you've
got the the swamps you've got war-torn
battlefields you've got so much variety
you go to these really dense cities and
while they are so like incredibly
packaged you can walk down narrow alleys
and the main streets and see something
different every time moving between
those also invites so much exploration
I've made it a point in the early games
of the era I was The Witcher 2 not fast
travel anywhere because every time I got
on the back of roach and went somewhere
there was always something new to find
the way that they built this world is
that usually in in open-world games they
make the world and then they fill it
with quests in The Witcher 3 they made
the quests and then altered the world
around it so that it never feels too
dense or too loose or too open or too
confining and there's been such thought
into it throw me wrong I think The
Witcher 3 is a beautiful world but I
think that not only is breadth of the
world a better open world than the witch
3 I think it's maybe the best open world
in any game ever and the reason I say
that is because Hyrule in breadth of the
world feels like it's alive it feels
like it's living and breathing that has
an ecosystem you see wildlife you see
remnants of this massive battle that
happened a hundred years ago and the
physics at play in that world just make
it feel like a playground so you can run
around set fire to the grass use that
grass to lift yourself up and it's so so
incredible to just explore and wonder
and under every nook and cranny you are
rewarded with the core exceeds
you are you were rewarded for being
curious about the environment seems
something on the horizon and thinking
yeah I'm gonna go over there I'm gonna
set a marker and see what there is and
it really rewards that curiosity witcher
3 has a lot to it just it makes you work
for it a little bit more which I enjoy
more cuz I find it much more rewarding
but you say it feels more alive to me an
open world feels alive because of the
people in it and I feel like that was
one of the bits in Zelda that was
missing out any town you went to it was
still pretty sparse where isn't witcher
there was hundreds of people and all
these people come together and all this
world comes together all the buildings
come together all the landscapes come
together to make like I said absolute
unit of a map but isn't that a bit
miserable just breadth of the world yes
it's tragic and yes you need to save the
world but actually it's just such a nice
place to be and I found The Witcher 3 so
uninviting breadth of the world you can
explore that world better than you can
in The Witcher you can climb anything
you can blow glad you brought up
climbing because ok The Witcher 3
originally had a climbing mechanic and
they took it out because they wanted
players to take their time in the world
but you've got you if you see a rock you
have to sort of walk around it and take
half an hour while they should be like
right I'm going over even if I'm a
Witcher I'm wearing chainmail i watch
swords i got bows and arrows and kit so
just like I probably too heavy to climb
links got about ten swords on his person
at any one time like sugar glass he's
even got nice climbing gear he can
change into and just you know go up a
bit quicker bandana from Guns N'Roses me
yeah he looks awesome which game has the
most satisfying combat
I think it's Zelda it has so many layers
that you can pick and choose what you
like about combat in Zelda first of all
you have a load of weapons this game
doesn't give you the best sword in the
game too much much later so you're free
to experiment with big swords small
swords sticks and that makes it so fun
to experiment and try different things
and you're always constantly switching
out on the fly and then on top of that
you have the whole physics of the game
and that really opens up to dropping
bombs attaching bombs to other things
downhills the gliding and dropping and
using like metal objects to drop big
crates on top of monsters or you could
wait until the monsters fall asleep and
then sneak into their camp and kill them
silently you can approach it from so
many different angles I think it's so
fun to just play with that and just its
feel so fluid that I things elder has
the best combat I'm not going to deny
those elders combat is enjoyable but I
don't feel like it's nearly as
satisfying as The Witcher 3 now I know
the Witcher threes combat was quite
tricky for some people but overcoming
that hurdle is the first first breath of
satisfaction that you get from that game
you have like the normal light attack
heavier stat attack stuff you can create
combos out of there same as you know
most RPG games but it's its depth and
it's breakfast is so intensely you can
fight in whatever ways you want first of
all you have two swords and they're not
made of bloody glass
you've got your steel to get anything
any organic organisms the normal
monsters the humans then you have the
silver to get ghosts enchanted monsters
anything magical out of the way and that
keeps you on your toes and you've
mentioned the tools your disposal at the
bombs and stuff The Witcher has his
signs so his five signs that can also be
customized to do extra things so you can
use igni to set things on fire you can
customize that to like a constant flame
storm you've got once to knock people
over but you can use magic traps and all
of that is it's all happening on the fly
I'm not gonna lie I do agree I think The
Witcher 3 has fun combat but what I
found was that I just ended up getting
into a routine with it and you brought
up the breakable weapons in Zelda and
that was a big complaint at the time
about that game but that plays so
perfectly into the world and the story
because you are surviving The Witcher is
about making what you do a which lives
out in the wilderness he he's also a
survivor and the breakaway weapons never
felt like survival to me it felt like
frustration like I can i got a royal
sword a royal sword like you'd imagine
that was crafted by the finest
blacksmiths in all of Hyrule and it
shatters when I shove it up a bacouple
Cobbins ass he's got a heart a heart
he's got is
get his ass out of here okay bullet the
breakable weapons yet it can be
frustrating early on but you do get over
that and it does become a thing where
you are actively thinking about what
you're using and should I be using my
weapons to do this or should I be
thinking about more creative ways like
rolling a boulder down the hill to kill
the enemy instead of just hacking and
slashing which I think gets a bit tiring
I don't carry up any of your Boulder
nonsense I want to chop monsters heads
off well you're not gonna go with the
Master Sword are you
no because it's gonna break no worry run
out of batteries it'll put me back in a
stone because I'm charge which game has
the best storytelling I mean you could
put a gun to my head and I couldn't tell
you what the Zelda story was beyond I
woke up in a cave and calamity Ganon is
now the smoke monster from lost witcher
3 is still held in its well-deserved
lofty first-place position for
storytelling some of the side quests in
The Witcher 3 are better than the entire
quests in some RPGs I can't think of a
better quest like when people talk about
amazing questing games things like the
bloody baron always turn up that's
that's like a benchmark for good quest
writing in RPGs now and it's good it's
got like the really deep stuff like that
and the the Tower of rats gameplay and
the create characters for like a
two-hour diversion they they realize
that people might not even see them and
you've got all that depth and all that
intensity and all that drama going into
a Zelda game
you do know what you're gonna get
story-wise Ganon is the big baddie
Princess Zelda needs saving most likely
and you play as link but in breadth of
the wild Link wakes up after being
asleep for a hundred years and he
doesn't really know what's going on and
you're encouraged to talk to people to
open your eyes and look at the landscape
and and see what's been happening over
the last 100 years and it's the
environment that is telling you this
story and that's what's so brilliant
about that gaming because the story
meshes so perfectly with the gameplay
and the world
it's the perfect Triforce if you will
okay betterment
and then there are flashbacks as well as
you do get pieces fragments every now
and again
so you're gradually building up this
picture of the world that was a hundred
years ago and then when you're ready for
it then you go on the epic final journey
to defeat Ganon and that is one of the
greatest moments for me in gaming is
deciding this is the time this is the
time to end this and to start a new
chapter in Hyrule and I'm gonna go up to
that castle I'm gonna knock on the front
door and I say wait Ganon you're going
down but the bridge of three has has all
that and more man like I did really
enjoy my time a Zelda but I just can't I
can't couldn't compare it you go in that
you're in this world of The Witcher 3
and you have to balance like political
strife between the cities there's a war
going on you have monsters every outset
you're trying to help the the common man
are also trying to unite these kingdoms
to save them from the wild hunt that's
still at your back all meanwhile
Garrett's got his own internal demons of
trying to find ciri who he loves like a
daughter and then when the game changes
and you progressed you play as ciri and
you get to feel the chase of that Wild
Hunt firsthand and get to see the world
from a completely different point of
view if all the stories didn't earn
their place in like the annals of like
great video game [ __ ] like the bloody
power and stuff that even the pants
stuff all these characters didn't earn
that we wouldn't be talking about them
today but you go into the witcher 3 and
for a lot of people it was their first
witch again so why do you care about
these people like you're told you have
to save ciri link and zelda there is
legend there is a hundred years of
history and you see that and experience
it and I think that The Witcher in the
setting is interesting but you don't get
big in you know this scale that this is
having a grand impact on that world I
think it feels very much like Garak
cares about ciri and yes there's a
threat but you don't really know who
they are you see them a few times and
fight them but they just don't feel like
this huge force coming down on the world
like Ganon is and his leaders are force
in the world he's knocking about a
castle he's letting you do your own
thing
he's just
is a wisp is a whisper in the wind
meanwhile the Wild Hunt is at your door
you've got politics to worry about and
there's a new cool piece of armour you
need to go craft this debate seems to be
going off course so we'll wrap it up
there but let us know who you think
debated their case better by voting in
our poll in the top right corner of the
video or if you're over on GameSpot calm
by putting your thoughts in the comment
section below
it'll be your votes that decide who wins
so make yourselves heard right time for
this week's quickfire round a series of
dumb fun questions written by the rest
of the UK team naturally daven will have
no idea what's coming their way
which character looks the best with
their top off link or girl it's easily
Geralt link looks like a boy so if he's
defending a boy you're wrong and
basically people are into boys garol
though he's a messed up isn't he he's
got he's rugged yeah but there's a bit
he's very torn
where's honest Linkous you see him in
his desert gear and it's just it's a
beautiful boy would you rather have sex
on a unicorn or abaca blade hundred
percent at unicorn I can imagine it's
been it's been it's tried and true
the unicorns a lot softer yeah but but
problems I imagine or a bit greasy sir
you know you've already got some
lubrication going know who would win in
a physical fight with swords and magic a
poner
or roach I think Roach would kick his
ass she's the best horse she can climb
onto rooftops Roach is a glitching
hacker so it's not a fair fight hummina
has a song does Roach have a song yeah
they're gonna play a funeral what Papa
Roach do your best link shout impression
oh yeah that was actually quite good I'm
also very loud illegal garel which is
the most Tory I reckon Geralt had no one
resent oh no because link is pure and
good he'd be definitely Lib Dem labour
maybe Green Party whereas Guerra Easter
does whatever he wants he's kills
monsters and the youngest monsters in
the world right now are the consist
remember to get your voices heard in our
poll or in the comment section below and
tell us who you think argued their case
better
and if you enjoyed this episode of vs.
make sure to hit that subscribe button
as well have new episodes of the show
every Wednesday thanks for watching and
I'll see you later
[Music]
you